mi viene da vomitare l tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti questo video sono fa vj e oggi
siamo sul nuovo videogame call of
cthulhu street
non ho idea di che giuro che non so che
cos'è per me l'avete consigliato in
massa appena uscito però non sia un
range game o un horror perché va bene
ogni bando alle ciance ciò il sole bande
sancho le panze ci vediamo tra poco o
gli amici che bello
thalberg e tim ferriss lippi press face
to sleep deduco che sia un horror credo
dalla che ha chiesto dormendo perfetto
che è fisico della madonna comunque
ragazzi a parte ciao
beh complimenti per l'ambientazione sono
veramente un figo comunque complimenti
belle belle scarpe della nike è un
giorno oggi è bello se si è fermato pure
si fermano al mi piace il picciotto quel
tizio appello lo zio aspetterà attimo
poi dice ma chigi i giochi e il
manichino non è un manichino una persona
non ha la faccia da scott azione come
cazzo di seguito la somma di capire è
bello
la mente un tipo sexy complimenti ei
tool palco da cosa cazzo appena visto
ragazzi c'è un tizio imposta sul
marciapiede non so se è normale che cosa
fai tu con le bolle che stoppa le
polemiche come i bambini ascolta la
prendo c'è la bre non l'ho presa ecco
perfetto salve ho mangiato parecchie
hamburger ruolo a sapersi ottima
partenza
va beh ok scotti signor corvo è andato
risultato può appuntare cosa devo
riuscire a capire ancora cos'è morte
imminente perfetto che anche grazie del
cartello c'è ma adesso sono contento che
paga mica madonna michael schumacher ma
è così poi così perché dei posti che va
bene sono in vacanza non so mai successo
con la vo visto non avevo giuro che non
l'abbiamo visto ragazzi sta diventando
tragico stagiona siccome tutto così
allegro perché non capiamo la canzoncina
divertente tutti quanti tifosi nella
vecchia fattoria io e quella la vecchia
fattoria e la vecchia a giudicare dalla
musica mi sa che la casa la famiglia tas
però è la vecchia fatto è che cazzo se
salite per oggi vorrei capire come come
fai un carretto della mente della minkia
come questo a salire ste cose
perché ci sta musica pronta regata
ragazzi
non lo so privati g dopo il cazzo
succede e sta musicando
mi viene da vomitare ragazzi i funghi i
funghi ovvio aveva fatto rocce
complimenti stop sta cosa
cosa sta vedendo se ho capito non l'ho
fatto il turn around girati salve
ascolti mimì taglia i capelli con
qualcosa no cazzo siamo cos'è cos'è sta
roba
cazzo sono ragazzi bello sono in avanti
sono in una pagina
ma che cazzo ha fumato sto tizio prima
andare a dormire che per questo dovrebbe
essere un sogno credo io non ho mai
visto niente di più sexy e sparito come
sparito dov'è andato a noi che mi
piaceva salve buongiorno ascolti io le
posso fare un massaggio vedo che è molto
teso
se mi fate spuntare dei ragni vi ammazzo
la mamma ti ammazzo anche al teramano
nella nota di denti anche noi che ci
starebbe male comunque
metti qualcosa mi ha abbracciato del
caduto il microfono fantastico gioco
dell'anno
giuro complimenti veramente perché c'è
tanta roba
perfetto ragazzi siamo sua alien mail
caos simulator lo devo baciare un alieno
credo che se fossero elio james uilcom
suo ok c'è veramente già scritto
barbaccia una foto i tuoi sogni si
avverano hanno certo non ascolta mica
sono tutti e due verrà veramente ma
veramente sexy brolio sono un maschio
quindi vado sul meno peggio io ti do
questo bacio il segno d'amore
ecco perfetto
ma salve sei veramente una [ __ ] della
madonna
ascoltate i ragazzi ora io io vi
insegnerò come come rimorchiare una
ragazza quindi prestate attenzione
allora tu sei la donna della mia vita tu
lo sai
vieni qua dove cazzo perché parte della
dubstep e quando non faccia stati già
tipo ragazze bruttissimo che cosa
sciocca ragazzi è una rom o ri ascoltare
temete che posso che si prova ad avere
una ragazza doveva fare latino guardali
che cosa sexy prima lezione ragazzi
allora tutti gli uomini ascolti non è
perché ci penso io allora ad un
appuntamento prima la guardate dritta
negli occhi e le ditte ei non ho mai
visto niente niente di più bello mi sto
perdendo mi sto perdendo nel tuo cenno
l'oceano che in genere che cazzo parla
di qua il cammi un bacio focoso che
cazzo palco gli occhi sexy
è la madonna ma devo fare parkour per
darti un bacio devo baciarci vieni
quando anche sexy scorta sia ci
appartiamo devi devo baciare tre volte
basta un andrè ma staremo qua che ciò al
posto del naso si usa anche per
riprodursi giusto per capire non lo so
ma perché riguardi così ho paura posso
berti la di fiere botin carkeek scusa io
voglio sapere macchina perché la persona
frustrata che ha inventato perché
qualcuno deve averlo fatto sto gioco
chi è che la fa voglio sapere chi l'ha
farlo voglio esigo sapeur muniain
higuain york a della madonna che sei a
my design nel passato di parecchi in
copertina bruna rivista è veramente
pigato di codesti che cosa triste si
vabbè mafia un macello come faccia a
faccia ti ovunque l'ex just friends
rimaniamo soltanto amici mi prendo nato
da un cazzo di alieno ma è possibile
alla mia l'aria proboscide soddisfa
qualsiasi donna sta frase può essere ma
l'intesa brutalmente tesoro non si può
dire che chi sta con te non fa
stretching faticose fa piacere che stai
vomitando della merda dalla volontà ad
essa in questo momento proprio mi
invoglia propria baciarti tesoro
ascoltami ce l'ho fatta l'ho conquistata
next year a rodi andiamo via di qui è
certo io io ci sono ci so fare con le
donne la gara adesso posso fare anche
l'altro nome lato maschio vabbè ci sarà
un pò gay la colpa vece tanto no vabbè
ma non ce la posso fare
sai la chimica e quel dimmi che quella è
una bocca di melo scott mi6
giuro che per soft come si esce qua
grazie tanto sei uguale alla tipo di
prima c'è solo il vestito diverso
sì vengo qua spesso il più fa piacere
che mi ha detto questa cosa sei molto se
che bello ascolta
magari non ce la posso fare non sono
sfilato su questo tipo di relazioni
ragazzi però si prova uguale sarebbe
bello complimenti veramente sensuale il
tuo sguardo mi fa perdere la testa di
udine ho paura della risposta che mi
darà la pena ma processi scacco dalle
bocche regali affetto ho vinto io ho
fatta rimaniamo amici si parla guarda
assolutamente se condivido in pieno
ragazzi per me va bene così comunque
ragazzi ho concluso spero che vi sia
piaciuto questo tutorial ma latin lovers
come conquistare una donna e un uomo
alieni quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto scusatemi se l'episodio durato
poco ma ho un mito 2 gameplay perché
sono era troppo corto se volete a far
avverare i vostri sogni seguite questo
tutorial e sarete perfetti al primo
appuntamento credetemi però prima di
concludere che mi dovete dire una cosa
ma cos'è questa roba che sembra un
cetriolo che ho al posto de cos'è
ditemelo voglio che si voglio saperlo
jordi ragazzi se il video è piaciuto
come si è tralasciato commento mi piace
anche a faccia di facebook e come non
divido tra tradizione e sui prestiti
sfigati lì ci vediamo al prossimo vi
dovete ragazzi